teaching classes
oh yeah well now that our boss is here
maybe we should start
so welcome everybody my name is Brandon
muramatsu I'm pleased to be here with
Jeff Merriman and then Cole Shaw we're
going to be switching off during the
presentations
um I'll start off hand it over to Jeff
Cole we'll do some demos we're going to
go for about 15 minutes with sort of
prepared presentation kind of giving
some of the background of the way we've
been thinking about this problem of
tools and how do you support the
authoring and delivery of course
materials if you don't want to put
everything into a single particular
platform or want to be able to deliver
to multiple platforms this is some of
the work that's been going on actually
in our group for quite some time now and
more recently in the last couple years
we've been focusing very specifically on
content assets and things to support our
mitx and edx instances and things that
we can also do to support open
courseware
so here's sort of the general problem
um our faculty and and MIT as an
institution is investing very heavily in
content this is something we've actually
been doing for quite some time now
um but as we moved into offering moocs
we're spending an even more larger
amount of time and effort both producing
course materials producing videos
editing videos creating assessments
doing all of the individual pieces and
parts that go into these courses
um and ideally we'd like to manage these
resources so not just leave them in a
folder on a hard drive or a folder on
like 20 different hard drives so if it's
in some of it's video some of its text
some of its PDF files but maybe be a
little bit more intelligent and
organized about how we manage it
and our solution and the way we want to
approach this problem is something that
has to support what we're doing with edx
and mitx also the things we're doing
with open courseware and then hopefully
the things we'll all we will be doing on
campus with our residential courses and
other activities uh like projects in
India or in Vietnam or or other
countries so we can take and reuse the
resources and assets either as a course
as a whole or individual pieces and
parts
and I guess lastly we don't want to be
doing this in a way where it's a single
monolithic fixed solution but something
that can and can expand and extend
um to other Technologies as they come
along to different products so we will
be doing this initially for delivery
through edx and through open courseware
but should MIT change its learning
management system we'd like to be able
to move the content and assessments and
activities into those systems as well
this is a very simplified and maybe
accurate or maybe not accurate view of
the way we've been we've been going
about doing these things so we've got an
MIT course faculty do the production for
it and then it becomes a course that's
delivered through our learning
management system perhaps just use in
the class itself and perhaps uh
used on a separate course website
separately we take those some of those
same course materials that once they've
been produced we take them we run them
through our ocw production process we go
through we clear the intellectual
property make sure that we can actually
release these materials under our
Creative Commons license whole
production workflow produces out through
and courseware and then we've been doing
the same thing to produce it out through
mitx and then edx
here's here's one way of thinking about
the possible future so let's take all of
that course input on the beginning and
be able to then use it in multiple ways
so instead of spending quite as much
time as we have been doing to produce
and re
um recast and and rearrange materials
each time for each different output
let's kind of do all that work up front
and then
figuratively push a single button to
push it out to open course or push it
out to edx or whatever new system might
come about
but hand it over to Jeff to talk a
little about our proposed solution
so the the
Direction we've been taking
um
for a few years now is is to Define and
and build out uh for services to support
persistence and management of
educational content
and related data around educational
content this is uh based on a bunch of
work that we've been doing with folks
various faculty and projects at MIT
including
safe here in channel the physics and
relate team who've actually been
speaking about their workbook as well
to try to get ahead of the curve and and
really thinking about how can we better
facilitate uh management reuse sharing
Etc of all these various elements
um
when I say service I mean what we tend
to call headless services so software
services with no native UI our goal is
to expose these the functionality for
Asset Management uh the uh whatever
happens to be the the the the the
popular important technology of the day
whether it's language specific apis
restful interfaces what what have you
these things change over over time and
then developing some key applications
that use these services so we can
actually deliver some
uh some some applications to seed the
environment and provide examples for
what we'd hope to be a growing software
developer community at MIT and that
started in a couple areas already
um so the thing that we're sort of
calling the backstage service Suite
we've been focusing on sort of four core
areas of content
um
uh one that's extremely important
particularly with the kinds of authoring
activities happening around mitx is
assessment assessments are kind of
special we have a special model for how
we manage assessments assessments have
items items have questions and answers
items want to live in assessments
assessments are offered assessments are
taken we have data around all of that
data about usage in NX courses data like
Dave and his team are are creating as
they inspect usage of assessment items
to create
item response Theory to run item
response Theory algorithms and get data
from that and we want to be able to
manage Assessments in a way where all
that data could eventually allow our
faculty to to to reuse and find out how
effective assessments were in the
context that they were used General
Asset Management things like PDFs and
and and links to to external URLs that
people are finding that think are
important for Education
video is a special uh a type of asset we
actually model it using our basic asset
model but but but but videos tend to uh
people tend to want to to deal with
videos in different ways so we think
about video Asset Management somewhat
separately and finally and actually the
project that is most far along right now
with us is is management of learning
objectives so we actually already have a
service that we are supporting since
last summer that's being used by a
handful of developers right now at MIT
to manage learning objective learning
outcome topic models relationships
between learning objectives as well as
relationships between learning
objectives
and the kinds of uh assets you might use
to to learn them to assess someone's
proficiency at a learning outcome
etc etc
we could talk about all these things
rolling a talk about a couple different
apps today the idea of course is that we
have uh we we are building and we're
trying to promote the use of these
Services as we develop them to build
applications that might use one or more
of these services to expose to users a
nice uh a nice Consolidated interface it
does something educational whether it's
creating educational experience or
educational authoring which is what
we're going to show of of materials that
can reach into these services and use
them together to store data to retrieve
data
Etc so we're going to talk about a few
of these a couple of these in particular
um and and as the conversation goes we
might sort of look at some of them uh
depending on what people's interests are
first of all this thing that uh we're
calling backstage producer
um this was uh there was some code that
we
um uh sort of received from the physics
relate team about a year and a year and
a half ago or so
um with this general idea of of how
could we better uh reuse the content
that was being developed for our edx
courses at MIT among this particular
particular Cadre of faculty and course
authors around physics
um we're going to show the proof of
concept that we've created that actually
is is being tested currently uh by key
guinea pigs around here who are willing
to put up with
you know early code
um
so who are in the room yeah we're happy
to have you here
um but basically you know what what this
Tool uh
is supposed to do is supposed to allow
us to better uh a course author to
better find assets have already been
used in in Annex courses to decide
whether they want not they want to to
use them to populate a new course
um and to uh uh uh you know to to buy a
nice nice search for that and in
addition let me show the so here's sort
of a picture of it so it's a tool that
doesn't yet but we expect as we move
Beyond uh pilot phase we would like this
tool to use all of these services that
we've developed
um I you know it's really an edx focused
tool right now I sort of think of as an
alternative authoring environment for
edx but the idea is that we all should
also be able to to package things and
pump them out for other sorts of uses
at MIT and elsewhere so what we can do
real quick here is do a brief demo of
this tool and then I'll come back and
we'll do a brief demo of a second piece
of functionality so coal Shaw who's
actually the the key developer for for
for these tools you're about to see
yesterday in this room when someone
tried to do a live demo the oil life
folks couldn't get their browser to show
up on the back really I know exactly
what you feel like right yeah I had the
same problem yesterday
same problem so uh my guess is this is
not gonna work
I don't know what was the secret
yesterday skip the live demo
I did an elaborate pantomime
drag and drop Dragon drop why don't you
talk assessments I'll talk about
assessments I don't know what happened
huh we'll have a highly trained
developer trying to figure this out
huh
yes I will fix the room
a few too many people
yeah it is
huh
yeah live stream
yeah a couple more seconds here
is also interesting doing this in
Spanish
and you know Spanish
okay we're eating into Prime discussion
times so
um let me just introduce the second
thing and then we can uh
um so
afterwards people come up with we can
humble around the screen
are you turned off Mary yeah
around
Wireless
stabilize this computer
all right
well
thank you
so what we've kind of done is is taken a
kind of like a studio add-on where you
can I don't know
I lost my Touchstone
you can essentially Import and Export
classes from Studio into the interface
where
you can pull things from other MIT
classes that have been uploaded into the
tool
and put them into your new class
so one of the
all right so we've broken up the edx
classes into each individual problem
each individual piece of HTML and made
them accessible to faculty to take one
and say I don't want the whole class
from Studio I just want this one A B
test I just want
the one chapter and here it is in my new
class you can save this you can export
it and import it into studio and now you
have all these extra components
um
one of the other things that people have
asked for is to be able to search
classes so
let's say I know that in my other edx
classes I've done a problem about
I have no idea if there's a problem
called this in
any of these classes
so there are some questions about
Newton's Laws somewhere
and you could take this and say oh this
is the problem I've used before I now
want to add this to my class
uh my edx class this this time
and we've we've had a couple of
different ways to search
um by like learning learning objectives
and but they're currently being tested
out
there
I will show the slide necessarily for
the next
play it currently hasn't booked into any
of the service services that we
developed Cole has backward up so it's
ready to sure and the uh but we've spent
a lot of time now this summer in
developing what we're calling an
assessment service primarily for
assessment management all things I
talked about earlier
um so that is going to be the first
piece of sort of integration that we're
going to be attempting with this tool so
take the basic UI take out the bits that
are that are sort of dealing with the
the edx XML structures directly and
actually deal with a live
interactive service where we can begin
to store and manage assessments and
actually have a richer set of data
around assessments
we're not ready to show that but one of
the things that Cole has started to do
is to begin to look at
um well the service we're developing not
only allows for for management
and uh searching retrieving of content
it also supports offering uh uh of
assessment it actually also supports
taking of Assessments in fact we have a
project we're doing with mass community
colleges we're going to use a service
directly to embed Assessments in
Blackboard and other environments except
the mass Community College but one of
the things the closer I look at is
actual assessment author uh particularly
with respect to some of the more
advanced
assessment types that are being used in
that X so so one is the drag and drop
assessment type sure snippet of that
yeah so a lot of the physics problems
that are being experimented with our
drag and drop type and so we have kind
of an alternative to the studio
authoring experience is a more graphical
authoring experience
where
you can directly kind of manipulate your
drag and drop problems
instead of having to figure out XML and
like exact pixels of where things are
located
um you just kind of draw everything out
you assign
your Solutions and this will spit out
the edx XML to you that you copy and
paste in your course
um so in the future we can imagine this
being combined with the other tools
where you just author things directly
into your course if you have new
problems or new new assets
and I guess for this where this is out
at X
or some other format right put it into a
different system
yeah that was part of the the goal of of
this was to not be wedded to one
particular platform one particular uh
sort of format for for for integration
um but to you know be ready and and to
support anything that might come into
our environment so that's sort of some
general Snippets of kind of what we're
working on software wise
um
that's our presentation what we really
wanted to do was sort of talk with you
guys about sort of what issues are we
all running into as we develop these
what are becoming pretty vast amounts of
content uh for our our mooc courses I
mean I know at MIT we have vast amounts
of content our physics department in
particular as a unit MIT already has
enough that they want tools like this to
be uh to be useful to be to be to to to
to support collaborative development of
courses
um in general you know uh so we're
hoping folks might talk about sort of
what you're doing in this space What are
some of the challenges that you're
seeing as we deal with with the
Platforms in place then the the issues
of of managing of managing assets we had
a set of we have a set of questions up
here how are you reusing content
how are you tracking data does your
course include learning outcomes one of
the things we're very
interested in are learning outcomes
linking learning outcomes to content
learning outcomes to assessments and
sort of completing a feedback cycle with
that
um so I actually have kind of a
technical question so um for developers
who are are building tools they could be
assets I guess I'm wondering what are
the requirements for making something so
that it can be sort of dropped in and
reused in your context
um so developers who are developing
tools that are like interactive widgets
sort of things yeah just just as an
example so my group we're developing the
the software that can host small group
Collaborative Learning activities so um
so in order to link it in say to
Coursera edx course we just had to
develop a wrapper for the LTI
um protocol but if I wanted to be able
to have people author activities using
this and then put it as a as an asset
what would have to be true about that
piece of software in order to make it
draggable and so the software is is a
hosted Service Plus some sort of uh uh
like JavaScript
it's not JavaScript it's Java so I guess
what I'm wondering is well maybe an
easier thing from your side is just to
say like what would it have to be
JavaScript I mean so what does it have
to what has to be true about those
assets in order for them to be so one
thing we're doing with the assessment
service in particular is we are also
supporting LTI which is a very
convenient way as you know to to to
embed these sorts of things thing so so
in that case we could imagine that what
you'd see would be you know the uh
within within backstage could be
something represents that particular
tool I like to use that tool in this
context we also need to configure
perhaps the LTI
around that so we're trying to support
those kinds of standards
um
uh we don't want to make these things up
if we don't if we don't have to uh I
mentioned the problem the project we're
doing with the community colleges uh LTI
was is a key part of that because
they're using Blackboard Blackboard
supports that we don't want to be in in
that case maybe it's similar to yours we
are actually hosting the assessment
engine
um
um and we don't and as part of this
pilot project we're doing but we don't
want student data for instance in our
system we don't want to manage it we
don't have to deal with the council we
have to deal with the FERPA issues
related to that we're just happy to get
you know what really amount to
um pretty sort of anonymized IDs that we
can store so at least we can understand
if somebody how far along in a an
assessment process how many
items they've taken so if they leave and
come back they can get the assessment
where they left it but leaving it all up
to Blackboard or edx or whatever the
host system is for the course to to deal
with the uh with with accounting and and
security around that sort of thing so
the fact of using LTI is is is is useful
in that space and we could look at the
tool we could figure out how that might
how that might fit okay
hi
um so how are you dealing with issues
like intellectual property so
um a professor developing content for a
course will that be accessible for other
professors people you can just take my
teaching elements and put them somewhere
else how how is that model so the
back-end service model is pretty
um
uh it it it's pretty rich
we have
a uh sort of a catalog structure around
all this stuff so with assessments
assessments and assessment items live in
Banks we call them Banks that's a
catalog hierarchical catalog structure
we can create banks will be people
access uh you know we give the owner of
the bank their own rights to manage
access privileges for their content
we have hierarchy in the model so you
could actually create sub catalogs that
you might or I might be the owner of the
entire I may have full privileges on the
entire structure but I want to create a
special catalog for my Tas that separate
from maybe one for for someone else
where I want to keep those access
privileges separate so we've actually
built that all into the service models
I've I don't know how deeply backstage
right now supports access control but
the the the the as we move it to
to rest on top of these service
interfaces that's how we're dealing with
it we're we're allowing
um the owners of the content to set
access access privileges for the things
that they're creating and how widely
they want to distribute those assessment
is a you know really good example of
something as we've learned more about
assessment and how people use
assessments the assessments are
interesting because well for a number of
reasons but one is because of the sort
of life cycle that assessments have
assessments become stale
as they get used you know the
information about the assessment gets
out there uh and then you can't use it
anymore so you can imagine and again the
reason we did the sort of structure is
you can imagine uh wanting to be able to
say oh you know this the assessments I
just did this past week they're mine
right and and we're going to use them
for a couple semesters but at some point
you know identify well these ones are
now available for self-study or or
openly or whatever so we want to be able
to support that we've designed the
Access Control structure to allow for
that
I'll just say currently I think it's
kind of like a share with who you want
to share with so I don't see all the
courses in there right I only the ones
that people share with me and it's kind
of we're kind of self-limiting that way
foreign
Coursera and then the people at our
teaching learning and Technology Center
decided to post Port it over to Ted Ed
um but the problem was my assessments
were based on multiple videos and tedded
only wanted assessments based on single
videos so they sort of had to work with
me and create new ways of doing the
quizzes because of the way it was
organized so have you guys addressed
sort of the difference so you mean
you're doing sort of like so in Corsair
I had a week by week
Arrangement and basically one quiz per
week right Ted Ed wanted questions based
on specific videos and not every video
that I produced had a correlating quiz
question so that the students went back
figured out which video is correlated to
which quiz questions but then realized
some of the videos did not have quiz
questions so have you guys encountered
sort of quirkiness
in terms of what the platform sort of
requires from your yeah well right now
is Blackboard for instance the way they
deal with with uh with LTI and grouping
so
um and I don't know how of course Sarah
works but um notion of assessment or is
it sort of
do do you do you group items into in
into assessments
and that sort of thing
or you just sort of create them and put
them where you want them
so we support sort of both those Notions
um uh uh so the idea that you might have
an assessment that you just want to
stand alone in a particular educational
process or a number of them you know
back to back
um but underneath the covers we have
enough abstractions assessment so so
items obviously are things that you
author that you know we can we can see
and manipulate and whatever and items
can be grouped into into assessments
using art the terminology we're actually
using in the back end right so so
assessment could have multiple multiple
items it might have other rules about
might want to state that an entire
assessment supports a particular
learning outcome or tests for a
particular learning outcome that kind of
thing
um we actually go further and and we say
you know once we have assessment you can
you can create an offering for that
assessment which becomes another object
in the database actually here's an
offering an offering has the attributes
of you might have a start time and an
end time you might have other things
that indicate that you know that it's
it's it's it's it's actually in play and
can be used by by students and then
finally we model
um the idea of uh what we call taken
assessments which are actually taken is
really a relationship between a student
and an offered assessment that captures
the data around how that how that
student did so I think you know what
we'd look at in that sort of case if you
had a set of items that you're using in
a particular context and I think it
actually works this way where it's where
it's of a bunch of of of of separate
items and then you want to move them to
a context where you actually wanted them
grouped for some reason or disaggregate
for another reason
um that does become an authoring
exercise so somebody had will have to go
and sort of drag those around or
whatever the UI is is for that kind of
thing I think what we're trying to do is
to
um
if you kind of looked at the model we
had like all the stuff on the left right
and then what we would need to do an
example of say going from edx to
Coursera and create like a little
plug-in on the right right we haven't
gotten to that point because we don't I
mean we're dealing only with edx but
we're creating the ability to do that in
the future
the the amplify Cole's point just a
little bit so as you would say what
we've got are the services on the left
models for those services and each of
the things I think everyone's been
bringing up is sort of an example of an
application and so as we get more
examples or need for to support more
applications then we start building
those applications to kind of do what's
needed
yeah I'd like to uh shift the discussion
a little bit to so you're a teacher and
here's this thing here
and you can assign
stuff from this library or other courses
and you reuse it are you actually going
to do it uh and if so why or if not why
not
um thank you for that question I am a
teacher and this is what I've been
dreaming about
um I think this is a great start
um doesn't quite get
to what I think is a global solution in
which teachers at many institutions in
different platforms can do it I realize
that might be very difficult and might
involve Technologies we don't yet
know that exist but this is exactly I
think what lots of us are looking for
we're not we don't want to import a
whole mooc or a whole or a whole other
course and then make that our own we
want to adopt things that we like in
other courses to our own so I think this
is a great idea
and this is a great service
it's not here soon enough for me but uh
but it's exactly what I would love to
see
so thank you for what you're doing so I
think I think about the the your your
hope that we can start to share across
institutions and across courses and
across platform types I think that's
something we absolutely want to support
and what we've been talking about sort
of is the technical a technical way to
enable that to be able to move between
systems
the the social or the community aspects
of that are just as challenging or even
more challenging I think that to find
institutions and individual faculty at
institutions that are willing to share
who have institutional policies that
allow them to share those resources
um and to be able to do it in a way that
sort of everyone's happy with who gets
access to what
um what's the currency of the realm for
how I'm sharing things back and forth
all of those kinds of things and and one
of the reasons we wanted to do this
session is to find out what other folks
are doing find out what other folks are
interested in and then see how we can
collaborate
where we can start using some of these
tools to produce the content that then
would be easy to share right now I have
no reason to use one or the other but if
you told me that if I use one of these
tools then that content could then be
more easily shareable uh to other people
then I would love to do that but I just
don't I just don't know enough about
whether this is available and whether if
it is available I can then put it in an
Annex uh
and so on so you to repeat the question
so the mic catches it it's it's one of
these tools are available now how how
can you start using either the services
or the tools and to to meet your needs
then I'll pass it over to Jeff to
address that yeah I wish I could say
this is all available now we're our our
our our
everything we build uh we we we we put
into open source this is what we do with
all the stuff we're creating
um uh this particular tool I I think if
we were to make it available like
backstage as it is being available to
the world I think Cole would have a a
fit
and and we are in discussions with with
with uh with with others here at this
college to try to figure out a way to
start extending this a little bit uh to
to to to start to figure out what a
community around these tools and
services might might look like
um so we're certainly interested in
talking about that it's just that we're
currently a very small team
um it's really just about one and a half
of us right now because I actually have
to write code for this too which I
usually don't do
um uh but we would like to start
extending that team but trying to do it
in sort of the same
way
so so this looks promising as we've just
talked about but I'm wondering to what
extent you're actually
only accessing content authored within
MIT versus potentially curated
collections of open content that come
from a more Global set of sources and
whether if you're not doing that
currently whether that's part of a
longer term plan
um
Brandon might have something to say
about this too
after watching about it we have a number
of projects outside of what we're doing
to support here at MIT that will have us
curating collections of oer as it turns
out and
um see how we integrate them with
various sources so it's kind of a
long-term vision and a
both the infrastructure that supports it
and then individual applications that
let us meet the sort of particular
project needs
so I didn't go into detail on how this
is architected but one thing to know is
that it's all based on a
um what what I tend to call an
implementation independent API
which means anybody could write
you usually apis like the ones exposed
by Canvas OR Blackboard or whatever
they're they're they're they're they're
exposed from that particular platform
it's only that platform that expose the
API Mac OS is a good example you know
you have a bunch of apis of your
software developer for getting at the
hard drive and the GPS and all those
sorts of things but those are specific
to writing Mac applications uh what
we've done is we've defined a set of
implementation independent API so
anybody could write to it and then we
could Federate across multiple uh
providers so if it's a technology that
um
that is really sort of already a
repository of content with sort of all
that repository management sort of stuff
an example I could think of another way
to hear from UT Austin UT Austin has the
quest uh system it's it's an existing
um uh uh uh question bank it's an
assessment bank that that I'm not sure
if it exposes its own API but if it does
we could certainly consume it in this
service and make that available loncappa
is one that we've used here at MIT uh
similarly it has uh and in fact it's an
example of a a global community of
Educators who who over the course of
what 15 or more years now have been
developing uh content and and sharing it
uh it has I'm not sure if Lon Kappa has
any hooks yet but it's the sort of thing
we can imagine implementing uh
underneath our services and and
providing access to
as far as content is available sort of
on the web
um we do have a researcher from Fujitsu
Labs is going to be joining us this fall
who's doing work in um
somatic analysis of existing content
particularly around learning objectives
so if you have or learning outcomes if
you have stated learning outcomes that
are already connected to to assets we
have some of that in our in our in our
learning outcome service already
um what can we learn from that and then
point the Fujitsu tool at another
collection and can we can we sort of
find similar can we find similarly
valuable content to the ones that our
faculty authored that might just be be
out there so there are things we're
experimenting with in that space as well
you say more about how the content is
cited so if I'm an instructor and I grab
a bunch of content and I make my own
course that's really a collection of
other people's assets how do I both as a
course author know where it came from
and how does how does my audience
understand better who actually created
that content in the first place how do I
attribute it
um
[Music]
the copyright and Licensing and where'd
it come from and all that sort of thing
the the service the the the the data
model behind the services actually we
have a whole number of records for uh uh
for for for licensing information
copyright information
um that people may or may not use right
so you actually have to author the stuff
with that data if you want it to be
exposed and tools that would reach in
that reach in to get this could can look
at that and can expose that to uh to
people who might be wanting to do
um uh
sort of remixes
um
we're not saying anything right now
about how you would expose that in your
remix I mean I think you know the
definitions of this that's where we get
into
um wanting and needing to track that
more closely and more clearly because
there's clearly we need to know the
provenance of where we got the materials
what rights do we have to those
materials as we move our production for
mitx into
um
a more kind of managed system we will
also need to be doing it for that it's
not a great answer but it's we haven't
built the application to do it yet and
it is going to be a pain in the rear as
Paul behind you will tell you
so so one of those elements could be the
the Creative Commons you know tag for
that sort of thing now what you do with
that we're not sort of saying right now
we're saying here's how you get it but
the tools allow you to remix are going
to have to worry about then how do you
expose that that Licensing in a remix
so um some of this seems kind of similar
to things that exist in other systems
including like content authoring tools
like soft chalk cloud has something
where you can pull it down and you can
search by Creative Commons license
everything is tagged by attribution
there's explore in Blackboard which will
actually go out to Merlot and
connections and all those places and
grab content and bring it in there's a
product that I just saw the other day
that was amazing where you actually
filter by Bloom's taxonomy obviously
there are limitations if you're just
using Bloom's taxonomy but in terms of
doing it instead of just instead of
looking for a specific objective you can
look for a kind of objective so my
question is are you exploiting or have
there been discussions in terms of
explaining the things that are already
out there or creating those discussions
around the use of like softchalk is
truly an authoring tool a very wysiwyg
like content authoring tool about how to
bring those things in so that when when
your system
so your system can talk to other systems
that are doing the same thing and
pulling from not just their repository
but a whole series of repositories in
fact softchalk we consulted with them
years ago when they were starting to do
their product they've they used an early
model an early version of our service
models when they develop their tool
but uh but again it's an example of
the idea behind trying to do this as a
implementation independent sort of way
is that we could write a plug-in for
instance for softchalk in learning
outcome space we're not currently
deploying it but there's a there's a
group out in California called ck-12
that has done a really nice job of
bringing together their K-12 bringing
together
State educational standards as well as
the national common core standards and
tagging a whole bunch of content that
their users are developing with that
they expose a restful interface to all
that and we developed a adapter so that
we can actually reach through when we're
doing stuff in in backstage and and get
to that if we wanted to now it's K-12 so
we haven't put a lot of effort into
doing that because at MIT we're not
seeing a lot of need from our faculty to
use K-12 content but it was an
interesting experience experiment for us
because we got to better understand that
kind of thing but we the the vision is
not to build these things ourselves if
we don't have to but leverage as much of
what exists but sort of bring it
together into a common interface that
that our community can write to and know
that the back end that Federation is
happening
think of each of those some soft chalk
is its own vertical that will allow you
to author an export with a common
cartridge which we can then take and
import there is additional information
stored within softchalk that might be
useful to pass on from an authoring
perspective but that's a tool and if you
don't happen to be using soft chalk then
how are you authoring it how what are
all of the other vertical tools that you
might take and want to Federate it
amongst
offering standpoint you can offer in
there and push these other places but it
also pull in better places
and by the way your comment about
Bloom's taxonomy so in our learning
objective model which actually helps
holds all these things together we we do
model cognitive processes and knowledge
of what we call it uh
the Blue Man's cognitive process models
and
the other one is but we have all the
bloom stuff the bloom-like stuff in
there not everybody uses Bloom we did a
project with our own teaching and
learning lab where they wanted a
knowledge category that's it where they
wanted uh to map what they consider
cognitive processes but they didn't want
to use the bloom ones they just use
level one level two level three so we
actually have a very flexible way to to
map different kinds of things in that
space if we need to
thank you
hi I'm Carrie from canvas Network
um because you've designed these LTI
compliant resources
I have a question about what you would
recommend to developers doing this and
this actually somebody in an earlier
session asked about projects for
project-based learning around computer
science wouldn't it be great if we could
get teachers to have students build LTI
tools that we could all then use that
would be great because they know it
works and what doesn't right but
thinking about softshop cloud
thing about ck-12 the quality of the
tools the LTI tools and the depth of LTI
integration varies greatly like at the
eduappcenter.com where you can integrate
into Blackboard and canvas and other
platforms these LTI tools it's a catalog
of different tools if you haven't seen
it when you add ck12 you get a hyperlink
that opens up to a new tab it's not a
very deep integration but something like
graph Builder the LTI tool is deep and
interactive and the students can
actually build and manipulate a graft
right inside of the course so how do you
develop this like what are some
approaches that people should be using
if they're thinking about creating a
tool to either solve a campus problem or
try to provide a tool that people can
use everywhere
I don't have a good a good answer for
LTI
in particular I've I've heard the
concerns of LTI and one of them is that
you simply you know you end up with
um also just a lot of sort of jarring
sort of different UI changes within
within your environment um because it's
really the service provider who's who's
um who's driving that this is why we're
doing
headless services and a lot of people a
lot of people are doing this right now
um the downside of headless Services you
still have to write the user widget
that that talks to it I think what we're
learning is it's not too difficult to
write those you those those widgets so
something we'd like to try to promote
and seal experimentation in is is you
know could we
could we explore a model where where
we're doing more of writing sort of
lightweight maybe JavaScript or little
apps that can embed in an environment
but still take advantage of what LTI
allows which is to deal with you know uh
a a system of record when you have to
for you know storing data or mapping
student progress or whatever that kind
of thing might be I don't particularly
have an answer
a lot to the usability of it as well
like you can build something really
great on the back end and what we're
seeing with a lot of LTI tools is it's
not a great UI either for the learner
experience where it's not as deep and
meaningful of a user experience as it
could be and for the teacher experience
certainly if it's not Plug and Play
they're not going to use it so it's got
to be dead drop dead simple and I'll be
honest our team at at the team that I
that I work with at MIT and odl and
we're we're not UI people and we have we
often Outsource our the final app
development
um because we're not good at that either
and that's partly why we're sort of
trying to promote the service model
because we think there's others out
there that can write much better user
experiences but in the end it's all the
same kind of thing whether it's
authoring an assessment or following a
pathway based on learning objective
model or whatever those things might be
that's sort of how we're trying to
approach that
one of the ways I think of it is
instead of building a monolithic app
we're assuming everyone's going to
always come to your application or your
instantiation and view of how you're
doing whatever delivering whatever
think about how do you let somebody
customize that a little bit
um I could show you an example of of one
of the things we're doing with to allow
any allow users whether you're I guess
an author to embed an assessment in any
web accessible content
embed an assessment a formative
assessment so we're not worrying about
Summit if we're not worrying about
security and making sure we know who you
are but it's just for you to understand
whether you're getting it or not and
we we built it with a with a group of
folks who understand
services and and
defining boundaries between what how
their pieces of their applications are
working
and what we're doing now is we're
allowing you to fame it and I could show
you a way of it's just applying a CSS
file to each to to what's going on but
you have to be prepared to offer that as
an option right so that helps some of
the jarring thing that Jeff was just
mentioning yeah
um and also to understand that from the
get-go we're planning to use these items
outside of the system in which they were
originally authored right and some of
the tweets I was joking making jokes
about either last night or yesterday
were about what if we had tools that we
could use across platforms wouldn't that
be great
uh whether they're LTI or they're
something a lot more uh complex and and
um rich and one of the challenges we
have I think is we have all of this
richness in the our edx courses and and
the interactive assessments and
activities that we're building in
JavaScript but are so deeply integrated
with that X right now we want to be able
to pull those out and use those in our
campus LMS or use them in a way where we
don't have to send people through five
levels of authentication to go into an
edx version which is what these guys
have been doing currently I believe
um
and it's it's
not thinking you're in a closed system
or and this is my only system but I want
to be able to use things elsewhere to do
this right in a way where I think that
that our users really want it to work it
takes a level of development rigor that
most people aren't willing to do it's
really putting those abstractions and
all the places they need to be so you
can have all you know you can have the
control you need if you're bringing the
LTI like tool into into canvas you want
it to automatically look like a canvas
thing right and that can be done
um but it it means spending a little
more Cycles in the development piece to
to put those hooks there Cycles either
which is really really frustrating I
think it's enough to be annoying to a
lot of developers is the problem
I hold many hats I'm volunteering but
I'm also like a point person uh as a for
my PA works on a introductory computer
science course at UC Berkeley and um
this is really really cool because
I was been trying to figure out how do
we get the content outside of the edx
platform and so like you're asking me
how else are we doing it we have this
other system where we're using GitHub to
store content and we're building out XML
like the XML core structure through edx
yep but obviously that's not the right
solution because there's so much great
content out there that that I want to be
able to use others so I guess my real
question involves
um how do I like it seems this is
awesome like this is really really cool
but
where like how can we Supply more
content to the system right so I know I
can if there are 12 courses in there I
can that have shared with me then I can
use those 12 courses but how do we keep
pumping in more information uh like I
feel like that might limit what what's
available for me yeah and and you know
the big issue with these kinds of things
is we're really good at building these
buckets but then you have empty buckets
right all right and people come and say
this is a great idea but oh there's
nothing there
um so
um uh you know what right right now what
we're doing and what sort of helped to
really uh jump start
the backstage app is that we're doing
the same we're basically sucking stuff
from from existing edx stuff uh GitHub
or or Studio I don't know where we're
getting from Studio or either right
um uh as we build out
the first thing we're going to do as we
build out the assessment service
um is we're just going to do the same
thing we're going to suck the existing
stuff and put it where it needs to go we
might not have done all the assessment
modeling for all the various kinds of
things it might still just be sort of
you know edx structure blocks of for for
a multiple choice question and we can go
and do a second pass and try to get
those multiple choice things where they
want to be in data so we can do all the
things we want to do for you know
pumping them out as qti or whatever we
want to do in that space
um so you know again we're not quite
ready to say give us your stuff
um I think the first step would be if we
can get these tools to the point where
we
um where you feel comfortable running
them at Berkeley I would say get your
stuff your instance and start loading
that don't worry about Federation or
about how we make them make it so that
our faculty can see your stuff and vice
versa we don't want to think of we in
none of the stuff we're doing do we want
to try to create a repository for the
world
nobody wants to manage that right uh
um lots of people set out to try and do
that yeah you you have experience I am
one of them I've done this in various
iterations including with Merlot it's a
losing proposition right but you can
curate for very specific uses for very
specific Collections and then we worry
about and if we do it right we can worry
about then how do we Federate across
those things via apps that can look
across various collections that's kind
of where we want to get to with all this
we got ta put a set of blinders on that
we want to do this and enable this for
MIT which is a big and complex and
distributed system which also means that
many of the models that we design and
put into place here will tend to work
elsewhere also and on the other hand we
have this
desire and belief in and that we should
be sharing what we're doing and so we go
out and share the tools share the
thinking and the knowledge
um we haven't mentioned but they could
go look at the service models if they
were really interested yeah people are
interested in in the technology feel
free to come up and I can point you to
to the websites
the service mod the service models
aren't simple they aren't just a simple
you know git and post things with giant
gobs of data and part of the reason for
that is that we want to design what
we're doing to be as transactional as
possible and we're pushing the
developers we're running apps these
things to write them transactionally so
instead of taking an entire set of
content in and then dealing with it and
then trying to publish that whole set of
content back we're sort of trying to
look more at the sort of Google Apps
sort of model where where you you can
imagine having a lot of people working
in an environment where we're all
authoring assessment items and attaching
to assessments uh if you're doing that
in bulk the issue you run into issues of
synchronization and and uh and and and
and and and and
journaling and rollback that you don't
really want to have to get into you want
to be able to try to edit small things
and if your edit complies with somebody
else's well you've only lost a small
thing right so so we're really pushing a
lot of I think interesting techniques in
all this and we'd love to
you know work with more people instead
of working in that space
I'm safe
um I I work at MIT I've been working
with you guys and Dave Pritchard and in
the physics department and I I just want
to emphasize something that I I uh some
people might have mentioned I've been
working with moocs for the past two or
three years
um I have 10 10 different copies of of
10 different implementations of the same
two courses my computer in in each
Physics course we have anywhere between
200 and 400 assessment items and every
run of the course we try to cycle
through a library of 15 years worth of
problems that we do here at MIT it's
impossible for me to know what is it
that I've done a year and a half ago I'm
working with 20 or 30 people that on on
creating content whether they were
faculty or students I think it's really
important for us if we're talking about
transforming education to I love your
question about you know how how can we
figure out the effectiveness of the
content
we ask the same questions in class year
after year and we have no information
that's stored anywhere about you know
the percentage correct I'm not even
asking about any any other metrics uh
and and uh uh it's where when I mean we
really need this tool or something like
this to offer any courses I don't know
about you guys but I I we cannot
continue sort of putting all these con
all this content to move if we want to
test it's really the next step after
you've created the course a lot of the
people that I've talked to they describe
the process of creating a mooc as uh
being the the most difficult thing
they've done in their life because it
takes you 100 hours a week for four
months to get to get a course up and and
it's very difficult for you to think
about how to make the course effective
how am I going to use it with my
students how am I actually going to sit
down and think about improving their
understanding and and figuring out their
misconceptions so I I'm just a big fan
of this work and I just I think that
everyone who's taught American's
thinking about running the mooc a second
time should really push for something
like this and I'm your biggest fan
laughs thank you sir
what about the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology as random things go on and
don't go on with our technology
although he's driving someone right now
to be fair
safe was actually it was a few years ago
now
when we hit we had those modeling
exercises we were particularly trying to
figure out how various of our faculty
thought about learning objectives
learning outcomes and linking those with
assessment so
many hours of whiteboarding activity
where we sort of taught you guys entity
diagramming and came up with it was
actually some of the real fundamental
work that led to a lot of this
um yeah so I really wanted to say two
things the first one is
if you look at any of the NRC reports on
discipline-based education research the
physics specific one how students learn
the number one thing they say to improve
education is used research-based
resources I haven't heard a talk about
that at all everyone
you know is just
okay so that's that's point one it would
be great if we could get resource
research-based resources in there the
second thing is the road this this road
is littered with failures
uh how many people here know about the
National Science Digital Library
how many people use it when they do
their course
okay
but it doesn't get used there are there
are Compadre in physics or Merlot there
there's tons of material there and in
fact I know very few teachers who use it
regularly let alone when they get a new
course go there this is a ins this is
not an insurmountable barrier because
mastering physics has a library and
people go there and two million students
use it and a hundred thousand teachers
use it now long Kappa which is open and
doesn't have all the the
the financial and personal might of a
publisher behind it they have a hundred
thousand hundred fifty thousand students
using it was ten times smaller than the
commercials things and that's that's the
only example that I know of a online
system where there is actually reuse of
material
and in fact you can look at long Kappa
what's very interesting is you look at
long cap over over the 15 years and you
see the number of problems assigned
going up and you see the number of uh
you know each year it's higher and
higher and you see the number of uh of
resources in there is flattening out
the rate of generation of new resources
does not is not proportional to the
number of resources used which means
that the existing resources are reused
more
and all of those systems the ones that
are successful have lots of metadata and
lots of vetting and there's a tremendous
amount of assurance and searchability
that goes into a teacher actually being
willing to use some piece of content
that they haven't tried before and I
think that's the biggest barrier in
these things you know whatever Technical
Solutions you have to go on material
from over there to over here the farther
you get it from I mean even within the
edx system there's going to be a lot of
variety and a lot of a lot of material
uh you know you're just going to have a
tremendous time blabbing something from
some other system that you don't even
know what universities use it and
trusting that material to use and I
think until you can overcome that
barrier these stuff will not be whatever
your bill will not be used I hate to be
so pessimistic but I think that's a
lesson of History
just a quick Counterpoint on that
um I I absolutely agree with you I think
that maybe it's not our Counterpoint but
the challenge is then
how do we build something that is so
easy to use where they can focus on
evaluating the content rather than
struggling to find what they need and
Implement what they need I think that's
a big challenge for adoption I agree
with you trust and and a cultural shift
is needed in order for people to adopt
open education resources but the
Technology's got to be there too it's
got to be dead simple easy to find it
use it cite it there's got to be
metadata we have to help each other use
this if we can build it people that have
the skills and the and the knowledge and
know how to build the back end get with
people who know how to build the front
end make the user interface so elegant
and simple and easy
hopefully we can make that cultural
change
if I may just add to that I think the
caution that you provide is really
important but if I look at the
progression of these things you know you
talk people talked about Merlot you know
and you had collection models which
required everyone to feed it to the
mother load right as different from a
Federated model where you say look you
know I mean when the Berkeley question
came up you know you do what you you
know you got your stuff and we'll make
sure so the finding getting using
problem was was a big barrier now you
say you can find get used but alongside
of these kinds of technical things which
make it easier to find yet right there's
also other developments that are
happening people are putting out rubrics
for Quality material much more than they
used to your point about
research based research qualified
material things that have where there's
evidence of working under different
conditions in different contexts so
there is need to build that kind of
information around that you know
provenance that's what I was saying who
did it under what conditions when was it
successful so this thing is not being
developed in I mean developments like
this are not done in isolation are the
only thing that's going on there's a lot
of recommender systems reputation
systems around content that are also
being built alongside which I believe
will facilitate this kind of sharing
that you know that the gentleman over
there said you'd really like
if if because before there might have
been quality content we can get to it
and if it got to it you can pull it down
if you pulled it down you can use it
right so some of that level of uh issues
that are being resolved alongside there
are other kinds of issues
the questions will be up here for a
little bit thank you
[Applause]